we begin with some breaking news the
author salman rushdie has been attacked
on stage as he was about to give a
lecture in western new york state
local police say he appears to have been
stabbed in the neck his attacker his
attacker has been taken into custody now
rushdie's book of the satanic verses has
been banned in iran since 1988 and is
considered blasphemous by many muslims
a year after the book was published
iran's late leader ayatollah khomeini
issued a factual calling for rushdie's
death
and i want to get the latest on this
story from our washington bureau chief
inez paul ines what more can you tell us
about this
well we learned that mr rushdie had just
come on stage and was seated in a chair
as a staff member introduced him when
the asylum rushed the stage and
assaulted the author by now we don't
know anything about possible motifs
eyewitnesses say however that there was
only one attacker who was dressed in
black we also
know that the man got arrested by the
police and that medical staff and police
were immediately there and brought mr
rushdie to a nearby hospital by
helicopter but as for now we don't have
any further details about his medical
condition and tell us a bit more about
salman rushdie and the history around
the fatwa that was issued against him
well salman rushdie spent about 10 years
under police protection living in hiding
actually after ayatollah khomeini of
iran called for his execution in
1989 because of his novel the satanic
verses which was considered by many
offensive to islam the book
was banned in india where saman rashi
actually uh is come and
is coming from was born and
where he didn't uh or where he wasn't
able uh to uh go back for more than a
decade uh the 75 year old novelist is
the son of a successful muslim business
man and he was brought up in england and
i think what is also important to
mention here is that the iranian
government announced in 1998
that it would no longer seek to enforce
the fatwa
okay inez poll thank you very much for
that this is a breaking news update and
we'll be keeping you posted
you